fed May provide as much as a 2 trillion
dollar in liquidity relief for banks
after Silicon Valley collapse JP Morgan
says uh the chase estimates that the
Federal Reserve may need to inject two
trillion dollars into the U.S banking
system after the collapse for uh of
three lenders last week this would help
prevent a run-on deposits and address uh
the scarcity issue in the U.S banking
caused by the U.S fed the monetary
policy the feds Bank term funding
program the btfp is an emergency loan
mechanism that will allow Banks to
obtain liquidity by putting up their
bond Holdings as collateral the FED will
accept a bond at face value instead of
their current market value has not been
qualified by the FED yet but it is
accepted expected to be significant
enough to cover all uninsured deposits
in the US GOP Morgan estimates that this
is going to be around seven trillion
dollars but suggests that the five
largest banks are unlikely to use the
program which would bring the actual
amount the FED provides to closer to two
trillion dollars does this sound like a
bailout why yeah of course okay why are
those big five banks not taking the
money because they have been subjected
to the Dodd-Frank regulations and they
haven't been able to get themselves in
this type of situation so to be clear
the feds raising rates this fast
explicitly to make more people
unemployed in this country explicitly to
do that that's it
that's their goal their goal is to
reduce inflation that's their first goal
no that's a byproduct no no that no no
look it's not a byproduct any more than
me like taking my hammer slamming it on
your hand and saying well both of your
products both of you are right but
Powell when he was asked if you remember
to hear him when he was asked he says
you realize and I think it was Kennedy
that asked him Senator Kennedy that said
hey you realize what you're doing is to
fix the economy you have to lower the
unemployment and then what did he say
Powell said
it could be a cause of it but that's not
why we're doing it it says no no that's
why you're doing and I know you're not a
Kennedy guy because he's a Republican
side but he's like no no that's exactly
what you're doing everybody knows it it
doesn't matter Republican Democrat
anybody who's honest knows exactly
that's what the plan is but do you
really think that's the plan do you
really think the plan explicitly the
plan do you think he said today by the
end of 2023 we need to have a million
people out of out of work I mean why
would they do that if they know it's
going to hurt the economy
because they they have one tool to deal
with inflation
and that is to raise interest rates as a
way of cooling the economy and cooling
the economy and and frankly I mean this
is the charitable view I'm I'm
articulating the charitable View and
cool the economy means as a byproduct
uh that you're gonna kick uh people out
of work in my estimation this is the
first time we've seen any type of wage
growth in decades in decades right the
the the the wages versus productivity
has been out of sync for decades and I
think frankly uh people don't want labor
to have any power you're seeing
increased unionization you're seeing
increased work action you're seeing
people saying like you know yes I
definitely you really think I do think
how is playing politics and increase
it's not politics this is what it is
though Union is a formal pipe your
policies Powell is one of the most
powerful men in the world today you know
that I know that right so when he moves
the uh he's controlling one of the most
important knobs right which is the rates
without a doubt yeah so but I'm trying
to think myself like I'm trying to sit
there and say okay you know when they
gave 1.7 trillion dollars in uh you know
relief hey we're gonna do this you're
going to do that or during covert hey
we're going to give 2.1 trillion we're
going to send people this much of money
this this that hey are they all they're
trying to do is they're gonna they're
trying to get people not to work right
that's what they're trying to do are
they really or were they doing it
because they're like dude I'm not
letting you work from home so I have to
send some money to you if you're getting
unemployed and I just laid off how many
people at the restaurant were
restaurants were crushed by uh covet
well I got to kind of take care of you
but then what happened with the money
the money went into the rich because you
know the low-income middle income
doesn't know how to save money and they
spend the money they're trying to make
it ends meet so sometimes you think from
the policies and you say oh they're
trying to do something really bad
you think Powell has negative intentions
or well he just sees this as a I don't I
I don't
I don't think I don't I don't think any
of this I have a different perspective
on how all this works I don't think that
Paul's sitting there going like it's
going to negative I just don't think
that these people care
I mean how do look how look we attacked
Iraq right 20-year anniversary yesterday
or two days ago
by anybody's estimates
we killed
hundreds if not hundreds upon hundreds
of thousands of innocent civilians
why
at this point this story we both aren't
the same page on we know what right
exactly yeah but but how is it that that
decision was made they don't care
about you that human loss and I don't
think Powell at the end of the day
really cares enough about the
immiseration of millions of people he
thinks the most important thing for the
stability of society is to save the
bankers Sam do you think I just disagree
Sam do you think do you think it was
healthy for us to go on a
128 month economic expansion only to be
disrupted by covet it would have
continued into honor you think it was
healthy to have interest rates as low as
we did for over 10 years I mean I think
there's an argument that you could have
crept them up uh you know uh slowly you
know up a couple of percentage points
but but I was also told listen in the
Arts when I started this job you know
you sound like the capitalist If you
defend that why I don't care what I
sound like I mean when uh during uh
during the the odds I was told that the
love lowest rate of unemployment we can
have in this country is six percent if
we have it lower than that then the
whole thing falls apart yeah remember
that of course we were told that was the
after like nature only allows that and
then all of a sudden that we can have uh
more unemployment I mean a lesson
unemployment we could have three percent
I mean that they there we are presented
by uh you know the these Powers
um ideas that happened that that
basically they're in a closed loop with
just other people who have power and
money and have decided that this is just
sort of the natural state of being and
it's not I I just I I just disagree with
that premise okay so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]